Buffalo un mercredi avant midi ce
directeur d'un refuge pour migrants
vient de recevoir un appel des agents
frontaliers une mer hongroise et ses
deux enfants ont été interceptés alors
qu'il tentait de se rendre au Canada il
doit faire demi-tour et non nulle part
où aller
sambary
il faut les mettre en sécurité dit-il ma
thèse le refuge vivait à buffelot
l'année dernière plus de 2000 migrants
ils ont transité près de 80% d'entre eux
voulaient aller au Canada principalement
par le chemin Roxane depuis qu'ils ne
peuvent plus demander l'asile en passant
par la frontière canadienne illégalement
beaucoup ne savent plus où aller selon
l'Agence des services frontaliers du
Canada depuis le 25 mars moins du tiers
des personnes qui ont soumis une demande
d'asile à une frontière officielle ont
été acceptées
ont augmenté de de 100% dit-il selon lui
beaucoup de migrants considèrent le
Canada comme un pays plus sûr que les
États-Unis c'est le cas de cette femme
sud américaine arrivée quelques jours
plus tôt avec ses enfants
elle pensait pouvoir rejoindre sa
belle-sœur en Ontario mais elle vient
d'apprendre qu'elle n'est pas considérer
comme un membre de sa famille en vertu
de l'entente sur les tiers pays sûrs
je rêve d'acheter une maison à ma mère
et de faire soigner ma fille au Canada
dit-elle
à la gare d'autobus de buffelo 7
militante informe les voyageurs et les
employés des nouvelles règles à la
frontière
elle veut éviter que des migrants se
voient refuser l'entrée au Canada ce qui
pourrait les empêcher de refaire une
tentative pendant un an ils sont ici
sont planes son plan B donc nous
laissons des messages d'aide
je te concierge d'origine portoricaine
Diadie plusieurs familles par semaine
qui veulent aller au chemin Roxane
il ne savait pas que les règles avaient
changé
en route vers le refuge matin ça prend
que la mer hongroise tentait de
rejoindre son mari réfugiés au Canada il
n'est pas optimiste quant à leur chance
d'y parvenir de sitôt
le Canada visible de l'autre côté du
pont de la paix est à la fois si proche
mais si loin dit-il
pour l'heure en tout cas c'est buffelo
qui sera la nouvelle terre d'accueil de
cette famille il Sandra nous liams
Radio-Canada buffelo